veteran journalists and curry spent most
of her career reporting from the front
lines watching history unfold curry is
the executive producer reporter of the
PBS show we'll meet again it reunites
people with important figures from their
past in an upcoming episode a Vietnam
veteran searches for the helicopter
pilot who saved his life after he was
shot down on the Vietnam Cambodia border
hi certainly felt a huge sense of relief
I thought we've been rescued against all
the odds Dave and his fellow soldiers
had survived thanks of the bravery of
Bruce Grable and his crew I didn't see
him until we got back to the airfield
and they kept probably gave mug and it
was just like - sure
you're welcome like kind of thing you
know I thought I know that wasn't
routine for him and curry joins us at
the table we should say congratulations
and curry you have a hit on your hand 11
million people watch this series last
season in your back again yeah and I
just love that man I do - Donson I do
too it shows you how you got this story
because one of the people watching said
hey and could you do this for me tell us
how these two got together well you know
actually we actually got a lot of people
reaching out to us at because and I
think because the series is reminding
all of us that whether we're caught in
major events like Wars or humanitarian
disasters they're people in our lives
who we have to thank who we might forget
if someone didn't remind us of the
series been reminding people but in this
particular case Dave's wife saw the
series and Dave saw it as well and they
but Dave's wife was really the one who
pushed him to reach out to us and so we
followed up on the story and so he's
fine
looking for the guy he was looking for
the guy and doesn't know if he's even
alive
correct so who didn't have to save him
Dave's under fire with a bunch of guys
they were in a helicopter that crashed
across the border in Cambodia they're
under heavy fire they know they're not
going to live it's really bad and he
sends out a mayday right before they hit
the ground and he doesn't know if
anybody heard it back at home base back
at the military base they actually felt
that they could not send another ship to
go get him but one guy who's delivering
heavy equipment in a Chinook who saw the
size of that yeah
don't go rescuing people initiation in a
Chinook goes and say and this turns
around to his crew and says guys should
we go get him we just heard the call and
everybody on the crew said let's go get
him and they risk their lives they came
in under heavy fire and opened up the
back of the Chinook and basically spun
around so these guides could run inside
and then they took off and everyone was
saved I mean it's such a rescue story
and now Dave you know wants to meet the
man the the pilot who made that choice
and so did his wife to say thank you
because without that we wouldn't have
the children where were they had little
children they wouldn't have had the
grandchildren that they have that's what
it was such an emotional episode with
the two of them when they finally do
connect and in this case you know you've
got a story and she's just a wonderful
interviewer does that's this quite
radical woman who's and her husband
served three tours of duty in Vietnam
this is a woman who served just like her
husband deserved and that's that's Dave
when he was junker caught you know in
another another the season also looks at
the women's movement and immigration as
well
yeah the women's movement which is
interesting because you know we are we
are in what I think is the third wave of
the women's movement the first wave
being the one that gave us the right to
vote the second one that gave women
opportunities this is the one that is
trying to get women pass those hurdles
right that's that prevent them from
reaching their full potential
and there are a lot of reasons that so
so we talked about the second wave and
and we meet women who not only did
something amazing because they have the
opportunities but one woman at actually
two women who actually risked their
lives for the Equal Rights Amendment and
what they think of where we are today I
mean that's really that and also the
Holocaust as well as none of our
subjects and in the Holocaust the
message of that one it seems to be don't
you know if there's somebody like this
in your life go find them don't wait
don't wait because that's exactly right
because I'm timeclick you know ticks by
and you don't know you don't know if
you've run out of time and you don't
want to run out of time but even if you
don't do run out of time there are
people who you can reach who would want
to know right
that's what Dave kept saying speaking of
time Gayle and I have a question for you
about yeah I know where we are in the
me2 movement yeah since you were last
here there certainly has been a
reckoning and it still continues yeah
and what do you think and as you sit
here today it will take four women to
reach their full potential what are your
thoughts on it
we look at you know and I'm just a
reporter so my opinion really doesn't
matter but I think if we look at history
what we notice is that it's it's
actually legislation changes in systems
and company policies these are the
things that actually cause real change
women coming out to vote were now we've
seen 100 women now in the house
representatives there are 435 third and
fourth seats and the house represents
last time I checked so so you know
that's not even a fourth really so we
have a long way to go so it's a
milestone but but it's about systemic
change and so the Civil Rights Act of
1964 was the legislation piece of
legislation that forced open the doors
saying you cannot just win eight against
women so that first step but it is a
very important one as is this serious
and great thank you so much for having
me you and you these two of we'll meet
again premiers tomorrow